ever wondered about the deepest desire  of scp-082  the smiling compulsive liar cannibal  known as ferdinand foundation  researchers snapped a photo of ferdinand  while he was sharing a meal with  scp-4820  using  scp-978 the desire camera and this was  the result  scp-082 performing at the paris opera  house as it appears in the 1986 musical  the phantom of the opera based on the  costumes and sets visible in the  photograph  scp-082 seems to be portraying  mesostopolis in charles gennad's opera  adaptation of fost while scp-4820  portrays the title character several  audience members are visible identified  individuals include peter dinklage  batman as depicted in early issues of  detective comics  scp-507 von cheney jr as the wolfman and  maximilian robespierre all visible  audience members have apparently been  moved to tears by  scp-082's performance